[Musica]
[Applauso]
mia nonna era tutta particolare mica mi
raccontava le favole
davvero piccola andavamo sempre a roma
per pasqua zio giorgio e zio paolo
faceva una gara che faceva l'abbacchio
più buono e noi venendo da milano
eravamo ospiti di mia nonna lei era
molto religiosa e la sera non mi
raccontava le favole mi raccontava le
storie dei santi ma io ero affascinata
da questi personaggi perché facendo
scelte coraggiose avevano messo in
discussione la loro vita hanno compiuto
qualcosa di speciale che ha cambiato il
mondo e io sono cresciuta con il
desiderio di fare anch'io qualcosa di
speciale
anch'io volevo cambiare il mondo anche
se non volevo diventare santa
quando ne parlavo con l'irruenza di un
adolescente mi sentivo dire se un
idealista e per tanto tempo ho pensato
che fosse sbagliato avere un aspirazione
così alta ero lasciata in sordina finché
un giorno è riemersa forte e chiara come
coach
avrei potuto nel mio piccolo fare tanto
bene alle persone e aiutarne tante a
fare qualcosa di speciale nel loro
piccolo insieme avremmo potuto cambiare
il mondo
sono partita da me
avevo 45 anni e la mia solita vocina
nella testa mi diceva ma dove vuoi
andare e già 45 anni poi flebile ma
distinta ho sentito un'altra vocina hai
solo 45 anni
quando sono andata dal mio trainer e gli
hanno parlato lui mi ha fatto un'unica
domanda a quale delle due hai scelto di
dar retta
è stato il primo incontro consapevole
con le sfumature
una piccola parola solo invece che già
aveva fatto una differenza enorme
come nel golf uno scostamento
impercettibile nell'inclinazione del
bastone durante lo swing può far sì che
la pallina accada dall'altra parte del
campo anche decine di metri più in qua o
più in là e oggi più che mai importante
avere una buona mira il nostro mondo è
sempre più diviso tra chi ha paura e chi
no chi si vaccina e chi no chi lavora
come mai prima
e chi fa fatica
chi è ricco e diventa sempre più ricco e
chi è povero e diventa sempre più povero
la pandemia avrà una coda lunga
l'abbiamo capito tutti ormai e notiamo
un aumento dell'aggressività della
depressione dei conflitti della
solitudine oltre che un significativo
impoverimento culturale dei giovani
in questa prospettiva dicotomica siamo
costantemente chiamati a scegliere e gli
ho scelto io voglio cambiare il mondo
non è un pensiero originale lo so
e meno male perché siamo in tanti oggi a
voler costruire un futuro più felice per
il pianeta è un momento di svolta tra
pre post pandemia un passato quello dei
miei genitori e dei miei nonni fatto di
guerre e il futuro dei nostri figli che
nel mio modello del mondo non può essere
altro che più green e sostenibile
per far questo serve fiducia creatività
passione
un progetto comune spirito di squadra
ricordiamoci che veniamo tutti dallo
stesso posto e che stiamo andando tutti
nello stesso posto
cosa stiamo creando oggi che rimarrà nei
secoli
io non so fare i miracoli ma so cogliere
e coltivare le sfumature
le sfumature sono quelle piccole
decisioni nella vita di tutti i giorni
che fanno la differenza e come nel golf
uno scostamento minimo nella nostra
percezione si può aprire scenari
differenti e portare a risultati anche
molto diversi nel lungo periodo
e allora giochiamoci un po con queste
sfumature
con un grande plastico lui e lei a cena
lei già giorni prima chiama l'amica sai
che sabato sera esco con lui e poi
parrucchiere unghie miss e si fa un film
della serata lui a volte condivide anche
lui si veste fighetto scura la barba
prenota al ristorante e anche lui si fa
un film della serata
quanti film ci siamo fatti
ora il cervello è micidiale valuta
costantemente una quantità
inimmaginabile di stimoli per la nostra
sopravvivenza e non ce ne rendiamo
neanche conto
cosa succede nel nostro film se quando i
due si incontrano lui le dice sei
bellissima lei apprezza la sua eleganza
a cena ridono scherzano conversano e la
comunicazione fluisce come non tango
sempre giocando cosa succede se lui
arriva in ritardo
se la sua macchina e un po troppo
vissuta e se per tutta la sera parla
solo di sé
dall'altro lato
cosa succede se lei quando scende un
trucco un po pesante e subito gli fa
notare che c'è una via più veloce per
arrivare al ristorante e lo interrompe
mentre lui sta dicendo qualcosa che per
lui è importante
l'esito della serata dipende dalle
sfumature
impariamo accoglierle e a coltivarle il
segreto per coglierle mi è stato passato
da un'amica tanti anni fa e quando l'io
diventato
mettiamoci in ascolto con umile
curiosità
per coltivarle mi sono ispirata al padre
della comunicazione nonviolenta marshall
rosenberg mi ha insegnato ad ascoltare
non soltanto quella che è la persona
dice ma anche quello che la persona non
dice l'intenzione le emozioni i bisogni
le aspirazioni
ora ti voglio dimostrare come l'ascolto
può fare la differenza nella nostra vita
ho scelto tre sfumature per me le più
importanti
la prima l'ho incontrata in autostrada
quando chiedo alle persone cosa vedono
normalmente mi rispondono macchina
autostrada cartelli nuvole montagne ok
ma la domanda più importante è cosa non
sto vedendo
questa sfumatura mi è stata utilissima
nella gestione del conflitto appena c'è
qualcosa che non va noi puntiamo subito
il dito sull'altro è lui il responsabile
e l'altro che non dice non fa non pensa
non è quello che vogliamo noi e così il
focus è sì sull'altro ma solo perché non
soddisfa un bisogno nostro in realtà il
focus è su di noi in una discussione tra
soci in un team di lavoro in una coppia
noi vediamo quello che apparente ma non
sappiamo mai cosa l'altro sta pensando
provando vivendo e quando ci si accalora
l'altro a volte comincia a vomitati
addosso non soltanto il problema
contingente ma già che c'è anche tanto
altro e parte una discussione in cui
ognuno vuole avere ragione ma quando
anche ti ho dimostrato che ho ragione
come mi sento davvero penso di aver
vinto e l'altro come si sente
siamo più vicini o più lontani
rosenberg propone una via alternativa a
questo approccio antagonistico
mettiamoci in ascolto di quel tanto
altro con l'intenzione di scoprire qual
è il bisogno non risolto che non stiamo
vedendo
perché tutto quello che facciamo lo
facciamo per un motivo per soddisfare un
bisogno i bisogni fondamentali sono
universali anche se non tutti si sentono
con la stessa intensità nello stesso
momento
smettiamo di giudicare e invece
impariamo a comprenderli insieme poi
negozieremo la strategia più efficace
per soddisfarli
come con una metafora io la chiamo il
secchio del vomito
chiedo scusa
se magari siete un po delicati di
stomaco ma tu sai benissimo se hai avuto
una crisi di vomito mai nella tua vita
quanto dura un minuto 2 minuti non di
più
allora quando l'altro cominci a
vomitarci addosso
porgiamo gli un bel secchio
bagniamo la fronte qualche parolina di
conforto ma senza metterci a giudicare
senza discutere ha bisogno di sentire
che ci siamo
quando poi sta meglio quando l'emotività
e scesa a quel punto mettiamo da parte
il secchio e insieme possiamo andare
alla scoperta di che cosa gli serve
magari non era così chiaro prima e
insieme possiamo trovare una soluzione
questa sfumatura mi è molto cara
l'ho vissuta come figlia e come mamma i
genitori sorreggono i bambini quando
stanno imparando a camminare scorgono i
loro talenti e vogliono aiutarli a
esprimerli vedono gli ostacoli prima di
loro e vorrebbero proteggerli
e così in questo rimpallo tra te lo sto
dicendo perché l'ho vissuto prima di te
mamma mi i tempi sono cambiati
vedrai se non avevo ragione non
ammetterà mai che avevi ragione
rischiamo di perderci la sfumatura più
importante una connessione a livello più
profondo
i nostri figli hanno bisogno di sentirsi
amati perché esistono non per quello che
sanno per quello che ottengono del film
avatar dicevano io ti vedo
io sono una mamma adottiva e pensavo che
il mio amore sarebbe bastato a colmare
il vuoto se non a cancellare almeno a
mitigare il dolore ho affrontato tanti
ostacoli e come tutti i genitori ho
fatto degli errori
oggi quando ci vediamo è un incontro io
mi metto in ascolto delicatamente
curiosa loro mi raccontano io mi
racconto e le lunghe chiacchierate che
facciamo mi lasciano intendere che la
nostra connessione si sta rafforzando
questo basta rendermi felice
poi le somme le tirerò alla fine
questa sfumatura e meno intuitiva ma è
quella che fa la più grande differenza
in assoluto a partire dagli anni 90 il
kart matt institute in california ha
effettuato numerosi studi
neuroscientifici sulla coerenza cardiaca
e ha dimostrato che il cuore è molto più
che un efficiente pompa che permette la
vita
oggi sappiamo che il cuore a un suo
cervello propri circuiti neurali e che è
in grado di imparare ricordare decidere
sentire
indipendentemente dal cervello il cuore
ci apre una fonte di intelligenza e
saggezza ci aiuta a sviluppare
creatività intuizione io l'ho
sperimentato in prima persona e ho
scoperto un modo diverso di ascoltare
la mia relazione con mio papà è stata
molto conflittuale quando era un
adolescente impetuosa a 19 anni un'amica
mi disse sai io non ho fatto in tempo a
fare pace con mio padre
quella frase mi ha inseguito per tutta
la vita
ogni incontro che diventava scontro mi
lasciava l'amaro in bocca e io mi
scervellavo letteralmente per cercare un
modo diverso per fare pace
ci sono riuscita quando ho smesso di
cercare chi avesse ragione e ho
ascoltato quello che avevo nel cuore
oggi sono felice per come evolute come
sta ancora crescendo la nostra relazione
ci scontriamo ancora ma ping pong
ho imparato che il cervello vuole avere
ragione il cuore sa
sarà capitato anche a te di prendere una
decisione dopo aver vagliato tutti i pro
ei contro
decisione che poi si rivela sbagliata e
tu senti quella vocina che dice lo
sapevo che dovevo fare nell'altro modo
ecco il cuore sapeva
ho condiviso tre sfumature
chiedermi cosa che non sto vedendo
ricercare una connessione
e ascoltare il cuore
ovviamente le sfumature sono più di tre
sono anche più di 50
ogni volta che siamo davanti a una
scelta
mettiamoci in ascolto sintonizziamoci
sull'altro con umiltà così potremo fare
qualcosa di speciale
e così potremo cambiare il mondo
e cominciamo dal prossimo incontro che
abbiamo con una persona
ci vediamo ci sorridiamo ci salutiamo
sento la sfumatura emotiva
quale che sia
cosa scopro che non avevo visto prima
forse non è così importante avere
ragione
cos'è che gli serve per stare meglio a
fare tutta la differenza è un io ti vedo
ora ti invito a portare questo valore in
tutti i tuoi incontri della prossima
settimana del prossimo mese del prossimo
anno e immagina che tutte le persone per
cui tu avrai fatto la differenza
faranno stesso nei loro giorni
successivi nelle settimane successive
nei mesi successivi
vista così cambiare il mondo un attimo
ti pare
grazie nonna
[Applauso]
[Musica]